this is from the daily wires it's an
organization that representative
Alexandria Kaiser Cortez is a member of
has accepted sizable donations from bite
dance the Chinese parent company of the
social media platform Tick Tock which is
Democrat socialist recently defended
from a possible Nationwide ban
Jake Denton a technology policy expert
at the Heritage Foundation noted that
Acacia Cortez is a member of The
Advisory Council for the Congressional
Hispanic caucus Institute in non-profit
entity they received 115 150 000 at the
end of last year from bite dance
according to a lobbying contribution
report what a coincidence Denton said on
social media
Casa Cortez recently remarked on Tick
Tock that a band of the platform of our
national security and privacy concerns
would be unprecedented and said that
such a move does not really address the
core of the issue which is the fact that
major social media companies are allowed
to collect troves of deeply personal
data about you that you do not know
about
she added that the lawmaker should
instead pass a broader data privacy bill
for social media firms
so we were talking yesterday we played
some of the clip of her uh she responded
to this move to potentially ban Tick
Tock by starting her own Tick Tock
account and trying to describe why she
objects to it and she said Doug doesn't
feel right so now we know where those
those feelings are coming from we know
why it doesn't feel right for her
because uh her organization is receiving
money from parent company of of tick
tock
I mean this is the kind of this kind of
open corruption that should be
investigated and uh and of course it
won't be and even if it is nothing will
be done about it
but that's what it is and I and and by
the way
should we look at a passing a a broader
bill that has to do with data privacy
and reigning and big Tech and all the
rest of it sure we should do that
there are many of us who have been
crying out for that for years
um
but you know big Tech should not exist
in this uh Zone in this magical like
law-free Zone where they could just do
whatever they want
and but that's the way that it's gone
for a lot of the big tech companies
um you know and it extends out to the
porn industry as well
some of the the basic regulations that
any other industry any other company
would have to abide by somehow it
doesn't apply to them so yeah let's talk
about that
but there's no reason why we can't start
with this bill
which to me is clearly a good bill
and I'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to the members block hope
to see you there if not we'll talk to
you on uh tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]